monessieurs je vous demande d'accueillir
Monsieur Michel
ler avec 150 musiques de film et presque
autant d'albums studio Michel ler fait
figure de monstres sacré virtuose fou de
piano le frenchy de 76 ans a joué auprès
des plus célèbres sinatraagil et psyol
train et plus récemment l'islandaise
Bork un touche à tout boulimique de
travail pour qui la musique est plus
qu'un sacerdoce quand je travaille pas
je me demande par que je fais sur cette
planète on a l'air comme ça d'être des
gens en pleine
liberté je veux dire
avec comme si on pouvait faire ce qu'on
voulait pas pas du tout on est des
artisans
formidablement rigoureux et toujours au
travail toujours discipliné au travail
il y a 16 ans Michel Le grandr passait
sur la scène de Montlouis aujourd'hui il
revient accompagné de son fils Benjamin
chanteur comme pap tout naturellement
que le jazz est devenu son métier sans
jamais que les liens du son ne prennent
trop de placeis unfant de la B
î et mourir je c'est un peu comme un
professeur quelque part sans lêre non
plus parce que c'est jamais quelqu'un
qui m'a imposé les choses ou qui m'a dit
ce qu'il fallait faire il m'a juste
montré qu'il fallait le faire bien après
ça vous le faites à votre façon voyez ce
que je veux dire mais voilà donc ça
prend un petit peu de temps c'est voilà
c'est comme tout on apprend on se trompe
des fois c'était pas toujours ça puis et
puis voilà et puis chaque concert est
diff
on en rapporte à chaque fois des choses
des émotions différentes des moments
dans certaines chansons des petit clin
d'œil des choses en attendant que père
et fils partagent à nouveau la même
scène Michel le poursuit son bonhomme de
chemin musical il travaille actuellement
à l'écriture d'un opéra avec é Emmanuel
Schmid et plus insolite il sera en
tournée américaine avec PTU la Clarc en